وفي المقابل تعرضت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
فجر اليوم ايضا لهجوم روسيل واسع
بالمسيرات هو الثالث من نوعه خلال 24 ساعه
وقالت الاداره العسكريه للعاصمه كيف ان
شخصا قتل واصيب ثلاثه اخرون اثر هجوم
الروسي وان قواتها الدفاع الاوكرانيه دمرت
اكثر من 20 طائره مسيره خلال الهجوم وصف
رئيس الاداره العسكريه في كيف الهجوم بانه
هائل وقال ان روسيا شنته باستخدام طائرات
شاهد ايرانيه الصنع فقط ومن جهه ثانيه
اعلن عمده كييف عن التعرض اربعه احياء على
الاقل لاضرار جراء ما وصفه بالهجوم الواسع
الذي تعرضت له المدينه ما اسهر عن اندلاع
حرائق في منازل وسيارات بعد تساقط حطاب
المسيرات عليها
لكن
في الساعات 24 الماضيه فقط
تعرضت للثلاثه هجمات بمسيارات بصواريخ
بغير ذلك وكنا معك حسان مسعود بالامس في
مثل هذا الوقت حينما بدات هجمات روسيه في
واضح النهار اولا ما هو رد الفعل من كيف
على
مزاعم روسيه بهجمات على موسكو وثانيا ما
اثر الهجمات التي وقعت فجر اليوم
نعم زين حتى هذه اللحظه السلطات
الاوكرانيه او اي من المسؤولين او
المتحدثين الذين اعتدنا ان نتابع
تصريحاتهم في مثل هذه الاحداث لم يعلقوا
على الاحداث التي جرت في موسكو صباح هذا
اليوم
وهذا اتى بعد ساعات قليله فقط على ما
استفاقت عليه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف من
هجمه موسعه ايضا بالمسيرات تتحدث
السلطاتنا عن واحد عن 31 مسيره انتحاريه
هاجمت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كياف اسقطت منها
كما تقول 29 مسيره بينما استطاعت ان تصل
مسيرتين الى اهدافها هنا في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كنا صباحا قد استعرضنا حجم
الضرر الكبير الذي اصاب واحد من بين
المباني التي تعرضت
للاصابه وللاضرار جراء هذه المسيرات التي
اطلقت نحو العاصمه كنا خلال هذه الليله قد
عشنا ليله صعبه للغايه ازعم انها غير
مسبوقه منذ بدايه هذه هذه الحرب على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف نظرا لان
المسيرات لاول مره تمكنت ان تصل بهذه
الكثافه الى وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه الى
هنا الى ميدان الاستقلال كنا نتابع خلال
الليله الفائته كيف تتعامل الدفاعات
الجويه مع هذه الطائرات التي تنطلق في
سماء ميدان الاستقلال في سماء وسط المدينه
وحتى تصل الى هنا زين عليها ان تقطع مسافه
بعيدا نحن قبل فتره كنا قد اطلعنا على عمل
الدفاعات الجويه في التقرير وكنا قد ذهبنا
اكثر من 40 كيلومتر بعيدا عن هذه المنطقه
هنا لكي نطلع على عملهم حيث يحاولون ان
يسقطوا هذه المسيرات على اطراف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه لكن المسيرات باتت تصل الى هنا
الى وسط العاصمه وتنفجر في سماء المنطقه
هنا حيث توجد المراكز الاساسيه للحكم
بالاضافه الى قصر الرئاسه خلف الكاميرا
وعدد من المواقع
باتت هذه المسيره تصل الى هنا تقول
الدفاعات الجويه والقوات الجويه انها تسقط
المسيرات لكنها في ذات الوقت تصل الى هنا
وهذا يعتبر بحد ذاته تهديد كبير للسكان
وكذلك للمراكز الحساسه هذا عدا عن ان عدد
من المواقع ايضا من الممنوع علينا ان نصل
اليها بعد هذه الهجمات بالاضافه الى مناطق
اخرى سمي حنان بالوصول اليها واستعرضنا
الاضرار فيها ولكن من الجانب الاوكراني
كان هناك تصريحات استفقت هذه الاحداث التي
جرت في موسكو نشير اليها سريعا ابرز هذه
التصريحات جاءت على لسان رئيس الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه خلال اليوم الفائت عندما حذر
بشكل واضح قائلا بان من يقوم بمهاجمه كيا
فوصف من يقوم بارهاب السكان في كييف ويريد
ان يعطل عمل من يقومون بمهماتهم هنا ربما
يشير بذلك الى الجانب العسكري وايضا جانب
ما يقوم به هو عمل الاستخبارات ان هؤلاء
لا يندمون وسيرون نتيجه افعالهم قريبا جدا
هذا ما قاله يوم امس في تصريحا كان لافتا
بعد الهجمه الموسعه التي شهدتها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ بالاضافه الى
المسيرات ايضا كان هناك تصريح لافت من
عمده كييف دعا فيه بشكل واضح رئيس او قائد
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
ان يقوم بما يجب عليه ان يقوم به لكي يعيش
سكان موسكو ما يعيش سكان كييف وهذا ايضا
جاء على لسانه في بث مباشر على احدى
القنوات التلفزيونيه
شكرا لك
بالاحسان مسعود مراسل الجزيره من